all right let's jump right into things
first of all definition recursion
procedure calls on itself
example the tree
the seed creates the tree which makes
more seeds
which creates more trees another example
humans human creates more humans
which create more humans
one of your lines of code is procreation
so why would this reality itself
not be recursive
that the trajectory
the telos is an oroboros
that the procedure of reality
calls on itself aka
we
make more reality
okay let's jump into things
from a
perspective of thousands of years
of studying metaphysics and
consciousness
we've had the ideas of non-linear
thinking versus linear thinking
with us for that long of a period of
time
what does it mean to live simultaneously
between the two can you hold
both perspectives at the same time in
the sense of
first and foremost you are eternal you
are infinite you are the
cyclical time time being an illusion
okay first of all and can you hold that
at the same time
of your biological clock ticking
right now you get 30 000 days to live
if you're gonna live until you're about
82 years old 2.5 billion
or so seconds slash heart beats
so you have to hold that simultaneously
with eternal time okay
because what you want to do given linear
time is you want to
actualize your gifts into the world
okay so we're gonna hold those two
simultaneously
cyclical eternal infinite time being an
illusion
at the same time as my biological clock
ticking and wanting to actualize
gifts into the world okay so the more
that you ponder
the telos the telos the purpose
of reality the more you ponder the word
infinity the more you ponder the word
eternity
okay the more you ponder the word
recursion
the more you ponder oroboros
the more you get ultimate reality
there's a really good song that goes
you might say that we've been here
before
okay think about that you might say
that we've been here before how many
times
has that happened to you via deja vus
via
all the different scenarios that you've
had where you where you think to
yourself
is this an eternal return have i been
here before
why does it feel so familiar to me
another way to think about this is
automata
in orthogenesis so very simply put
that there is a automatically making
an auto making process and there is an
orthogenesis a unilinear
evolutionary process towards an
attractor
okay what is an attractor it's what a
it's mathematics of what a complex
system evolves towards okay
so the recursion is at the god head
and that's the attractor and the
mathematics of our complex system
is evolving there via a automata
orthogenesis
okay and you can think about this like
john von neumann one of the smartest
people who's ever lived
the universal constructor okay and
what does it mean to make a
an iteration or a mutation
in that tape of that code that is
evolving
it means doing something as simple as
creating
the capacity for humans to fly in the
air
one human gets the imaginative idea from
watching
birds and goes we need to do that and
the next thing you know
they're assembling an airplane they're
flying an airplane somewhere around 100
plus years ago
and then boom here we are 100 plus years
later
there are over 100 000 commercial
flights that happen
every single day across the planet
that cut down travel time across an
ocean
from weeks to less than a day
it creates more empathy it creates
more gnosis of the other
as the self okay
very profound and that's all
that you have to do steve jobs and so
many other people have said it
just look around you every single thing
around you
was created by the imagination of people
that decided to seize those ideas and
just relentlessly obsessively
execute them into the world okay it's
that simple
you have to push to achieve
beyond what is just the 40
of what is david goggins
and dave blaine and so many other people
talk about
is us just being stuck at that 40
percent of what we can achieve
work harder achieve your full potential
fast more work out more sleep
better execute more stay focused
such simple things will help you get up
to 45 percent of your full potential
50 of your full potential hold your
breath under
water for 30 seconds then 35
then 45 then 50 then 55 then a minute
and keep pushing yourself and just feel
that incremental pace of yourself
becoming more and more self-actualized
to your fullest potential
fight against the incessant
ghrelin that the hormone being called by
your body
i'm low on glucose i need to eat right
now
i can't work if i don't eat yes you can
yes you can you can burn fat you can
enter ketosis
you can stay focused on the project that
you're trying to execute into the world
that's how you achieve your fullest
potential
that's how every single greatest mind of
all time has done it before now you take
the 100 plus
billion people that have ever lived
before us
and only one percent of them somewhere
around
one billion people are the ones that
seized
ideas and executed them into the world
they made those iterations and the
mutations in our
evolutionary trajectory that gave us
all of the beautiful abundance that we
have today
and the other 99 billion were common
be the uncommon amongst
uncommon people
ultimately when you ponder that telos
when you ponder our evolutionary
trajectory
you get the idea at a deeper level when
you look at
virtual reality when you look at
simulation theory
when you look at artificial general
intelligence when you look at all these
things that people from even a hundred
years ago let alone a thousand years ago
that were studying metaphysics did not
have what we have now is the most
beautiful way of immersing ourselves
in what is ultimate reality it's so
simple every single person that puts on
virtual reality for even 30
minutes and uses it and then gets
out of it thinks that's that is thinking
deeply more critically about the world
takes it off
and they go how the [ __ ] is this not
already virtual reality it's that
simple think about it
it's such a clear mirror it's such a
clear
hint that we are evolving towards that
telos it's all triangulating
even the west is triangulating via agi
simulations and virtual reality on the
same thing that eastern metaphysics has
been thinking about for
thousands of years as ultimate reality
john smart calls it the transcension
hypothesis
the fact that we look out and we see
there's nobody else in these
massive star systems that exists yet for
us to find out
fermi's paradox enrico fermi where is
everybody
well guess what it is highly possible
that where everybody goes is of course
it's important make life interplanetary
go and create beautiful bases on the
moon and mars
and go and explore the the moons of
saturn and jupiter
looking for life on europa and enceladus
and titan
is very important and very fun
but it's also super important to think
about
virtual reality agi simulations and
transcending
in inward inward at the same time as we
go
outward why is inward so fun
why does inward have such a deep calling
as a recursive function
let's think about it this way
why do you think people like
video games so much why
is a great example japan as dan fajal
likes to say a canary in a coal mine
why why are there so many people around
the planet obsessively playing video
games
ponder that for a moment why
may it be because we already exist in a
video game
may it be because they by playing
video games they gain the ability to
feel like gods
maybe that's why maybe when you pick up
the controller
or when you immerse yourself in a
virtual reality
what is happening is you feel like
a god and you awaken to the
fact that you already are a god
we all are maybe that's what video games
give us and maybe that's why they're so
damn popular around the planet today and
that that's the trajectory where they're
going
you are god you pick up the controller
the virtual reality you enter into the
environment and you are the god
you get to decide when you want to exit
out of that world you get to decide what
quests you want to go on in that world
you get to decide
what accolades you want to get in that
world you get to decide
how you want to level up what attributes
you want to level up
think about it that is exactly what you
get the opportunity to do right now
you are infinite potentials and you
get to pick if you want to stay
at a stagnant static 40 percent
or if you want to achieve your absolute
maximal potential across
every single category that is possible
for you to achieve unleashing your
fullest divine unique gifts into the
world
by pushing yourself harder okay
there is going to be very
soon and we'll all be seeing this this
decade in the next decade
an infinite amount of designer realities
for us to immerse ourselves into
okay the idea being that
given the significant computational
powers that we are unleashing
and given the absolute indistinguishable
realities that we are designing and
those incredible graphics and
sensational
ins and centeratory experiences
that we are building that
we are unleashing so many
different combinations of what is
possible for creative virtual worlds
that you will get to pick what you want
to immerse yourself
into any time and you will find that to
be fascinating
because one moment you will be in the
normal
math and physics of a of a universe just
like this
and you'll be exploring what it's like
to be on the planet and going between
the
the wall of china and the eiffel tower
in machu picchu
and you'll go back 500 years and you'll
live in the enlightenment you'll go back
2 500 years to the time of buddha and
then so you'll
bounce around like that but then guess
what you'll do then you'll go
and you'll jump into new styles of solar
system design
and then you'll be like okay cool well
all our solar system has this star in
earth and it has
these amounts of planets and it has
these big planets like jupiter and
saturn and whatnot
and now what you do is you go well what
if it what if i enter into a different
style exoplanet around a different style
star system and they have a different
style of life that has evolved
and you go and immerse yourself into
that that will [ __ ] blow your mind
that will blow your mind will blow my
mind and it'll blow all of our minds
because that's what's coming and there's
even a step
beyond that the step beyond that is to
design
virtual realities that don't even follow
the same
laws of math and physics as our universe
does
so all of a sudden you'll be immersed
into these abstract
realities that you just can't comprehend
it's so much more difficult
for you to understand it's not simple
dna double helical carbon based life
forms
in that style of coding it's different
and we get to design that and we get to
understand what actual infinity
means as we go through that style of a
recursive auraboric
process and you just
think about this reality when you
realize that you
are the publisher and the player we
are the publishers of the game and we
are the players
of the game the deeper that you embody
that as
the gnosis as a gnostic being the more
you realize that
the more you realize that we ourselves
have designed and
buried the actual codes we have buried
the codes think about it
think about it for a moment where are
the codes buried
there's this titration of remembrance
that's happening as we're evolving
we're unlocking more and more of these
remembrances
that are waking us up think about it
we've talked about so many of them
ai virtual reality simulations even back
thousands of years ago people could tell
that dreams were a crucial hint
what about all the shamans on the planet
and all the ways of leveraging the
beautiful
entheogenic plant medicines we literally
we encoded the secretions of plants
to wake us up to ultimate reality
we are the designers we wrote those
codes
and if you don't see plant medicines and
if you don't see
dreams and if you don't see vr and ai
and simulation technologies as
codes that we ourselves programmed
to remember to remind us what ultimate
reality is
contemplate that more that will help you
a lot
and think about it also in terms of
octaves it's so
musically beautiful you can think about
it this way if you would like
here we go ready c 2
3 4 5 6
7 c 2 3
4 5 6 7
c right that's the auroboric
moment when we go from seven to eight
is the auroboric moment
and so many people have talked about the
evolution from three to four which is
where we are
at right now hypo the hypothesis is that
we're going from e
to f right we're going from me to fa
doremi faso la tito right from
me to phi and what that means is we're
going from service to
self service to self i'm self dealing
i'm obsessed with my ego to service to
other
to other which means that i am serving
you because i understand the divinity
within you
that you are me that we are the one self
that the mathematics
of the infinite is diversity
in oneness thank you sri aurobindo in
the mother mira alfasa
love you both so much and so that
is our evolution and notice how there is
no e sharp
which is very interesting and what that
means is that it's very hit or miss
okay that either you're going to get it
and you're going to understand
service to other and our future or
you're gonna stay in the ego in your
service to self mode
and that you're not going to get it so
get it faster
wake up faster push yourself to wake up
faster to service to other and where
we're going
you have the full potential inside of
you
to awaken to it unveil unveil
unleash the kingdom of god within you
unleash those beautiful unique gifts
into the world
and this plays every combinatoric
forever
infinity eternity this beautiful dream
symphony that we are a part of plays
every combinatoric
forever that is the logic of the
infinite the fact that we are
um we unleash an infinite amount of
illusory affinity
as a validation mechanism that we are
truly
infinite that is the logic and that's
why the logic is also recursive
an eternal self actualization
loop eternal self actualization
loop eternal self actualization
loop it's a key thesis of the
project that we are releasing and that
becoming
is the only being the only being that is
available
is an eternal becoming and that's what
we
are and that's what's going to continue
happening forever
ultimate reality is nearly indescribable
nearly indescribable don't let
people tell you that it's not possible
to describe ultimate reality
don't let people to tell you that it's
not possible for us to uncover our
source code
because it is and we are and we are
going on that recursive process
and that ultimate reality needs the best
storytellers possible the best
synthesis the most general
generalist polymaths possible to sponge
up
all of the novel peaks on the fitness
landscape
and then create the story of what
ultimate reality is
and disseminate that in such unique
millennial gen z and generation alpha
consuming ways
that we all wake up way faster
that's our role with our show
so that's why simulation in 2020
and beyond this decade is going to be
unleashing the best synthesis
the best storytelling around
ultimate reality so buckle in
buckle in because that's what this
channel is
that's who i am that's what i'm
unleashing into the world
and you're here early and remember that
the earlier that you are here
the more you have an advantage you have
an advantage
that you are taking in the most cutting
edge
understandings of ultimate reality and
you
by embodying that sharing that with
people and building up on top of it
and working your own unique creativity
with it
will get to level up we're shooting a
portal to
you jump through the portal and enter
into
a new dimension of thinking about where
we are heading who we truly are and
where we are going and what we truly are
okay remember this reality is recursive
an eternal self-actualization
loop one of the lines of code
of reality is to call
on reality we're making more it's an
eternal cycle simultaneity of the
eternity of time
with your biological clock ticking and
wanting to
actualize your unique gifts into the
world
this is your heartbeat
you're only going to get two and a half
billion of those if you live until
you're about 82 years old
so you have to have simultaneity in
those two things
reality's recursive eternal
self-actualization loop
that's the automata orthogenesis
to the attractor of the godhead in the
transcension hypothesis
contemplate it more agi virtual
realities
simulation technology infinite designer
worlds
the logic of the infinite contemplate
these concepts more i'm leaving you
what is a very important trail so
dive into this trail the more you do the
more you'll pick it up
and the more you pick it up the more you
can create gifts from it build on top of
it
and wake people up to where we're going
okay
i love you very much remember also
that the mathematics of the infinite is
diversity in oneness we are one being
and we have all of these diverse unique
individuals that are expressing gifts
into the world
so unleash yours go beyond that 40
stagnation
static-ness go way beyond that challenge
yourself
love you very much thank you for tuning
in everyone such an honor and a pleasure
to be able to have people that care
about
what we are bringing to the world as a
gift
so thank you very much i'm honored
and privileged and i'm very grateful and
buckle up
we're bringing some insanely beautiful
things forward
and uh i'm just so grateful thank you
everyone
thank you thank you thank you thank you
let me know more
as you go through this process let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
about where you're getting along this
process i want to hear from you
i want to hear from you we're going to
have some bonkers things lined up where
we'll also be bringing the community
together in person
so i'm so so pumped thank you everybody
thank you
you guys know what to do subscribe if
you haven't like the video share the
video with other people
awaken people faster and um
truth ultimate reality
number one nothing's more important than
that
it's that simple dedicate yourself
obsessively
to ultimate reality and the truth and it
will yield
it will yield